welcome everyone to columbia university
particularly want to extend my welcome
to the old entire delegation from
Georgia it's very nice to see so many
familiar and friendly faces as well as
our students and and and primarily to
the the prime minister of Georgia Rock
Lee gabashvili and I have a feeling that
you didn't come here with all the
cameras and everything to hear me speak
so I'm going to be very brief and just
take this opportunity to welcome you we
we we like to think that we spend a lot
of time on Georgia and have some
thoughtful discussion about Georgia here
at the Hermit Institute and I'm sure
today's discussion will be very much in
that tradition so please join me in
welcoming prime minister of georgia to
columbia into the Hermit instafit well
thank you first of all I would like to
thank Kalam universe for given this
opportunity to speak of it to you about
Georges progress and roll is a reliable
and Steve first ally of the United
States let me also thank our friend
Lincoln Mitchell for this kind
introduction and it's an honor to
address the steam notice today as part
of my first visit to the United States
as the prime minister of Georgia so
thank you again well while this is my
first trip to the United States as Prime
Minister my previous visit to the
country have given me a greater
appreciation for what American
friendship means and in that regards
regard Georgia's friendship and with the
United States is one of my country's
most precious assets this trip has
already been a great success I had a
great meeting with the present with vice
president with secretary Kerry and also
had a number of productive discussion
with senior other government officials
and congressional leaders on how we can
make the Georgia us relationship even
stronger we have also met with the NGOs
and business leaders to discuss how to
move George's economy and civil citation
to the next phase of development and my
government
the clothes strategically important
relationship with the United States and
I see great potential for future
political economy can secure the
collaboration between the two nations in
between the countries Georgia has
learned over the last 20 years that no
matter what political party is
empowering in this country the United
States the United State has been as
chief SLA and friend to Georgia and
following this trip I became even more
convinced that all Americans should know
that Georgia's Americans true and dear
friend and ally no matter where what
pelicula party is in power in Georgia
Georgia America's interests the line and
its friendship runs deep and the beauty
of democracies that although the captain
may change as we say the ship none
remains one course I could also go on
about the strong bilateral relationship
but I want to talk to you today about
Georges comprehensive democratic and
economic reforms and how they are
contributing to George's path to
European and your Atlantic integration
however before I do that I would like to
express my deep concern over the
alarming events in Ukraine as I know
they remain foremost on all of our minds
you've given recent developments in this
country in Ukraine and I would like to
express my condolences to the families
of the Fallen citizens it is a tradition
it is clear now that the Ukrainian
people express their preference for free
association with Europe and the
sovereignty and territorial integrity of
Ukraine should be respected at any cost
any unwelcome foreign involvement in
Ukraine's domestic affairs should not be
tolerated Georgia remains committed to
the prosperity and security of the Black
Sea region and we support efforts to
find a peaceful solution to this crisis
over the past 20 years
georgia has grown tremendously as a
young and vibrant democracy we have
emerged as a true leader of stability
prosperity and security in the region
and appreciate the resounding support
from the United States from European
Union from NATO as we have pushed
through comprehensive reforms to
strengthen our country's democratic
values in economic freedom our
commitment to align in more closely with
United States and Europe goes
hand-in-hand with our commitment to
continue democratic transformation
increase your Atlantic in European to
Grayson is our way of returning to the
family of European nations with whom we
share history culture and most
importantly the values this idea is
supported by the Georgian people in all
major political parties the outcome of
the october2013 presidential election
served as a clear demonstration of
European aspirations of the people of
Georgia more than eighty percent voted
for candidates advocating for George and
integration with her European Union and
NATO Europe is where Georgia belongs and
nothing can derail us from the track of
integration by initially the association
agreement included a deep and
comprehensive free trade area at the
villain summit last year November we
opened a new chapter in our relations
with European Union when is it that the
insist that the European Union analogous
Georgia's European perspective those
paving path for the membership in the
European Union it is obvious that unless
the European Union gives clear promise
of membership to the successful
countries of the Eastern Partnership
then crisis similar to Ukraine will
happen again and again and this crisis
main spin out of control outside the
region we are ready to be your
neighbors not just neighbors for Europe
we have initiated and implemented key
political economic constitutional and
judicial reforms directed towards
strengthening democracy in our country
the rule of law judicial independence
transparency and social welfare as well
as respecting human rights and
fundamental freedoms in 2008 at nato
summit in Bucharest the alive decided
that Georgia would become member of NATO
later the Alliance underlined the
importance of holding free and fair
parliamentary and presidential elections
in Georgia the progress already made
puts us and that that really puts us in
a strong position to take the to take
next step forward in Georgia's native
integration for Georgia the upcoming
NATO summit this fall is the best
opportunity to adequately assess assess
and reflect the progress made by us by
our government and i think it is
essential to move forward and the
realistic way to do it is to grant
membership action plan to georgia with
stress on map as it is a single
integration mechanism providing concrete
framework for the implementation of the
bucharest summit decision that georgia
should become member of nato key
domestic reforms have paved the way for
Georgia's progress and I want you to
save your words and highlight a few of
them first of all I believe one of the
most important achievements on my nation
has been our commitment to democratic
reforms and the success of the October
presidential elections in the
parliamentary elections of 2012 the 2013
elections have been widely praised by
international observers as free and fair
my country has come a long way in a
short time and there is much potential
for the future is a model of democracy
democratic progress in the region
another key benchmark of Georgia's
democratic consolidation has been recent
constitutional amendments that created
more fair system of checks and balances
amendments that between the legislative
and executive branches my government
remains committed to ensure a free and
fair independent and transparent
judicial system through risen to
constitutional reforms the courts have
become more independent and have readily
regain the trust and respect other
people protection of fundamental human
rights and freedoms including minority
rights are also among our key priorities
this includes our new national human
rights strategy and action plan that
designed to bring the country's legal
and institutional frameworks as well as
human rights culture and practice in
line with the European standards within
seven years no other country has a plan
like this I can probably say it was
developed in cooperation with all
stakeholders and with the advice of
outside experts like EU special
representative Thomas hammer break the
plan touches up in law enforcement the
judicial and penitentiary systems the
labour market social services as well as
legal codes and institutional national
and local government structures progress
will be measured in officials will be
accountable for implementation we will
finally turn George into a consolidated
democratic country that was promised for
so long in addition to sweep and
democratic reforms Georgia is poised for
an era of economic growth we have made
great progress to ensure a free
an open economic environment in our
country and have undertaken numerous
reforms to further advance economic
opportunities for both the domestic and
international businesses our country is
open for business and we welcome the
opportunity to continue to deepen our
commercial ties to the United States and
in fact us Georgia trade is a on a
forward trajectory as more and more
Western investors and companies are
feeling confident about opportunities in
Georgia and are coming to the country to
invest we're committed to the
fundamental principles of economic
freedom and protection of property
rights and have work to foster a free
and fair and transparent business
environment through the creation of new
employment opportunities inclusive and
affordable systems in the field of
education health care and social
insurance we are improving economic
opportunities and the quality of life
for all your Georgian citizens our
economic success has been recognized and
applauded by the international community
the World Bank recently forecasts six
points represent economic growth for
Georgia in 2014 instead of five percent
as which originally envisaged a recent
survey to the Heritage Foundation ranked
Georgia as this 22nd freest country in
the world citing improvements in six out
of 10 economic categories including the
management of public finance investment
freedom monitoring freedom and property
rights the same survey ranked Georgia 12
out of 43 countries in the European
region in my country country score is
well about the regional average I also
want to say that Georgia ranks number 8
according to the World Bank use of doing
business criteria and I was tedious
commitment to Western integration
extends beyond our domestic democratic
and economic reforms we are
also committed to increasing our
engagement with the international
community on key security issues and
georgia is ready to take the next step
in its partnership with the west serving
is a large contributor to international
security through a robust cooperation
initiative on non-proliferation
counterterrorism and peacekeeping
efforts as the largest non-nato
contributed to the I submission
Afghanistan our troops and our
government are committed to this
important endeavor we are committed to
staying in Afghanistan through the I
submission and are ready to assist in
the process of institution building by
sharing I've experienced in this regard
friends as my country moves forward on
our path to your Atlantic and European
integration our relationship with Russia
remains a challenge we appreciate the
resolve and support of the international
community particular United States as we
try to lower tensions in our relations
with Russia but I want to underline
Georgia remains committed to seek in a
peaceful solution and normalizing
relations with Russia the previous
government on the two of the pledge not
to use force in pursuing occupation
which we reach iterated in 2013 and our
country introduced the visa-free regime
for the citizens of Russia and agree to
Russia and sessions to the World Trade
Organization in order to normalize
relations with Russia we start to
explore various areas of cooperation
without detriment to Georgia's
sovereignty and territorial integrity we
achieved some results such as the
gradual opening of the Russian market
for Georgian products Georgian wine
mineral water and agricultural products
also improving of transport links and
improved humanitarian and cultural
contexts but we plan on continuing this
commitment to cooperation in the future
part of this includes our decision to
participate in the Sochi Olympic Games
where we sent our athletes it was a
difficult decision by the way to
participate in in Sochi however we are
committed to for forging a new
relationship with Russia and finding a
peaceful and sustainable solution to
border ization however despite the
progressive and peaceful efforts and
constructively policy of my government
unfortunately Moscow continues its
provocative and destructive activities
such as the installation of barbed wires
and fancies along the patient line by
the way they just renewed these process
two days ago right after the sochi
olympic games well we expect further
attempts from the russian federation to
increase pressure and georgia as russia
refuses to reciprocate Georgia's legally
binding on use of force pledge and
remains in breach of EU mediated august
12 ceasefire women's nevertheless for us
there is no at native to a dialogue and
political settlement of the conflict a
final solution takes time we understand
consistent tragedy strategy and
consolidated international effort my
government will continue to work closely
with the European Union and other
international partners and friendly
nations as to avert any further
deterioration of the situation the
geostrategy geostrategic dynamics of the
Black Sea are constantly changing
continuing us support for Georgia is
increasingly important for the with the
prospect of further provocation from
Russia and the increasingly
deteriorating situation in Ukraine We
strongly encourage the United States
European Union and NATO to continue to
play a key role in shaping the stability
and prosperous future of the region it's
not only about Georgia it's about the
region
continued support and engagement with
will resonate and we'll deliver a
powerful message democracy a value-based
partnership and the democracy a
value-based partnership integration with
the European community can be successful
in our neighborhood and lastly Georgia
successful European in your Atlantic
integration will not only benefit my
country but it also bring greater
stability and security to the entire
region moreover the integration of a
strategically located transportation and
energy hub into at euro-atlantic space
service provides long-term economy
convert an advantage to our partners as
we move down this path and in the years
ahead we will continue to serve as a
reliable in stage presence at light of
the United States we appreciate the
support of the United States as well as
at the international community as we
strive to achieve sustainable progress
and success and look forward to
increased engagement closer economic
ties and continuing political
cooperation in the years ahead as we
continue on our path forward we are
confident to Georgia's future political
stability economic prosperity and peace
thank you for attention
Thank You mr. Prime Minister I we now
have some time for some questions
there's a microphone in the middle
between the two aisles if you just have
a question if you could kind of stand up
and get near the microphone and then
stand in line as you or as you ask your
questions please be so kind as to say
your name your affiliation and then try
to keep your questions brief with with
an emphasis on questions not not giving
speeches so I have my good friend David
Phillips well that's the first question
mr. prime minister david phillips from
columbia university very warm welcome to
you professor Mitchell and I and others
from Herman haven't visited your country
and we've looked at the occupied
territories and developed plans for
civil society contacts commercial
lengths we tried to be as innovative and
creative as possible to break down some
of the barriers that have been built up
unfortunately the situation seems to be
worsening with the construction of
permanent Russian basis what's your
approach to the occupied territories and
how can his your national friends of
Georgia be of assistance to you thank
you well it's a it's a good question
well first of all I'd like to tell you
that Russia continually bored raisins
project process which they started in
2011 and last year they installed 50
kilometres of barbed wire fences and
artificial barriers so in December they
stopped this process and right after the
sochi olympic games two days ago they
renewed this process well our approach
is the following since we came into
power in 2012 after the parliamentary
elections we entirely changed our
approach reserved it to Russia we
changed our
LLC and it became constructive yes
constructive as possible first of all we
appointed Prime Minister's personal
representative for Russian relations and
my government has undertaken a number of
constructive Terran steps which was
aimed at disk elating the tension
between Russia and Georgia and I think
it worked as I mentioned in my speech
Russia gradually started to open its
market for Georgian products we could
sell our products and improve economic
and trade relations with them but these
efforts didn't really much effect on the
protocol side we still have this unsold
conflict with Russia and they're
propagated action in the occupied
regions both challenges and problems for
for our relationship it really doesn't
help to rebuild the trust between the
nation's and therefore my vision for the
occupied regions is the following my
country has chosen our way which is
called a Georgian way which means
countries europeanization by initially
in the association agreement in in
Vilnius the country's your integration
became irreversible and now when I say
irreversible is what gives me the i mean
the the the power to say this first of
all the will of Georgian people we made
public servant opinion surveys several
weeks ago and it shows that eighty-five
percent of the Georgia population
supports countries European integration
and eighty-one percent of the population
supports NATO integration and that gives
me more power that gives me more energy
and it encourages us to move forward
Georgia has made a choice between paths
in the future we want to move forward
toward the future I really want to
transform my country into a real
democracy it's a real modern democratic
and European State we want to transform
Georgia into a better place because i
think my you know my nation just
deserves it and we simply this is our
choice this is the choice of the
independent nation as for the vision how
we can reintegrate the how we can
persuade our brothers applause ians and
no settings that this is the right way
this is the right choice I think it's it
should be done in the following way
we're moving in the right direction
we're making necessary reforms economic
reforms bring in more and more investors
we're going to increase economy we're
going to improve the social condition of
our people we're going to make better
healthcare better education for our
generation and I think in after after
three or after five years people in the
occupied regions they will understand
the difference they will understand
difference how will leave and how they
leave in the occupied regions and they
simply will want to live with us and
share with us with all these benefits
kanter is your integration means that
Georgia will have a free visa regime
with European
Union just a simple example Georgia will
have a free visa regime with European
Union I'm I'm confident very soon maybe
in Euro to maximum so just very just an
example so we will offer a posse encino
settings to travel with George and
password to Europe without a visa this
is one benefit we will offer them better
education better health care and better
social conditions and the most important
thing is that we will offer them freedom
freedom that this is the most important
thing that every nation needs in the
world so I think this is this is the
vision this is the only right approach
how we can attract our brothers now we
can persuade them there there's no
better place for them to leave rather
than to live with us with Georgians of
course there is no as native to a
peaceful dialogue and we will never use
force against them thank you McCain
Institute Fellow organization accessible
environment for everyone I'll be back in
Georgia in August and taking studies
here first of all I want to thank you
and congratulate you with ratification
of UN Convention on the Rights of
persons with disabilities we were
advocating for it for several years and
at least it's achieved I want to
underline the importance of its
implementation as government took the
obligation and responsibility into
sure the equal opportunities for persons
with disabilities to access healthcare
public transportation education
employment there are lots of things to
do what are your concrete steps in the
nearest future for its implementation
because I want to say that this is a
revolutionary document for developing
countries like our country and it's it's
the post-soviet approach was like to
focus on disability the convention
offers us new approach to focus on
ability so what what what what is your
administration's plans in your future
thank you thank you Georgie thank you
for this question as you mentioned we
ratified the convention last December
and my government has also adopted an
action plan a five-year action plan
which means that we have to each
government organization in each
government institution it will have to
comply with these regulations and we'll
have to for example install the the
ramps and another necessary i think i'd
say the steps that we have to make so i
think what we can do we can share with
you this this action plan so that this
will be give you this will give you a
very detailed answer and information
about our program thank you haibach
tango Malawi Social Democrats of Georgia
my question was in regards to many
statements that Georgian dream has made
when it said that its center left and
there
is social democratic given so my
question is what are specific economic
labor and employment policies that this
translates into and are you going to be
using any of the American expertise in
this process thank you very much thank
you well first of all I'm glad to to see
that summing Georgian students arrived
to to join us and baktun gamma Larry's
was my deputy when I was the Minister of
Interior so I was glad to find out
there's another Rock Tacoma Larry here
in these days well first of all a life
say that our government the new
administration is a first of all people
oriented government and I think we've
proved it many times we introduced
entirely new approach towards towards
human being and we declared and we
proved that for us for our government
the most important value is is a human
human being we entirely change the
government's policy towards health care
you know that we increase the budget for
about 1 billion Larry for the ministry
of health care and social affairs and we
continue we're making a lot of reforms a
lot of changes in this regard as for
economy you know that our government a
top priority is the agriculture because
we believe that there's a huge potential
and that's this is one of the top
priorities for our economy goes and to
reach our economic goals I can tell you
that last year we made the number of
successful projects such as the
assistance of about seven hundred
thousand citizens we help them to to
work to cultivate their lands and we
spent over two hundred million Larry in
that project and we're going to sponsor
the same project this spring and we're
going to spend about 100 million Larry
this year and and we have other you know
other other programs and other projects
and to tell you I think this is the only
right approach because people live in
poverty in Georgia they live in very
difficult situation especially in
regions in towns in big cities they they
have more jobs and etcetera but in the
regions there especially in a very
difficult situation so we're doing out
necessary or our best in order to help
them in order to create more jobs and
this is one of the this is my biggest
challenge honestly the economy is my
biggest challenge and create more jobs
unemployment this is the this is the
biggest challenge and we are making
we've already done elaborated and a
long-term strategy it's called 2020 how
the country should avenge would be
developed in the years ahead and just
recently we drafted a national program
an action plan how to develop the local
production and this program is called
produce georgian because our problem is
that the the goods are mostly important
from outside eighty-five percent of all
goods are important up from outside and
we don't produce them so we're going to
start we're going to help the startups
we're going to help small and
medium-sized businesses business
companies this year so in order to help
facilitate the lives of
people especially in the regions thank
you hello my name is Amy berchtold and
I'm an alumni of Columbia but from the
medical campus and I've had the good
fortune to visit your beautiful country
a couple times and my question is you
refer to all the progress Georgia has
made over the last 10 years and most if
not all of that progress is due to the
former government of saakashvili yet it
seems as if your government does not
recognize his party is a legitimate
opposition party and many of the many of
its members are are actually imprisoned
at the moment many high-profile members
I was just wondering if you could
comment on your attitude towards the
opposition party well thank you well
first of all I'd like to tell you well
added I didn't want to speak about the
past because i think that's that's it's
our past history and since we're you
know forward-looking government and i
didn't want to waste my time thinking
about them people already made a choice
and they voted for us they voted for
Georgian dream because they believed
this was the only solution to to save
the democracy now country I aren't
aligned to save the democracy in our
country because that was not the
democracy especially in there isn't in
the OD if you look at the over last year
I mean what wiII happen in 2011 2009-10
a two thousand eight and seven how there
were brutally dispersed in the
manifestation peaceful manifestations
and by the way I can tell you that five
people died in 2011 when they virtually
dispersed in peaceful manifestation in
Tbilisi on May 26 and over hundred
demonstrators were jailed putting jailed
and tortured and I don't want to speak
about this again but since you asked I'm
obliged to answer to your question but
and the you mentioned you asked about
the former government officials
some of them were prosecuted and my
government had a legitimate reason to do
so and the most important thing is that
transparency only the due process and
rule of law guide us in all these cases
it could name a case where these three
elements are not guaranteed then I will
apologize but I can guarantee you that
all these cases are extremely
transparent we invite international
monitors expert to comment you need to
attend these trials and see where you
know how these trials are being held so
that's Mike well I mean that and of
course that's the judiciary that's the
independent court's decision and it's
not us to decide who to be jailed or not
and most importantly I like to repeat
what I've always already said many times
I think we should not set the sense of
immunity impunity I said several times
and I'm happy to repeat for you today
I'm the prime minister of Georgia and
after five years or ten years when I
resign when I live my office and if the
new government finds out that I will
come into crime my question is should
the new government prosecuting or not of
course they should why because I'm not
privileged i was elected to serve my
country to serve my people not to serve
my own needs and deserve my own family
this is my answer and it's very simple
transparency rule of law and due process
everything else is is being taken care
by the independent court thank you yes
hello I thank you so much mr. prime
minister for taking my question I'm
Victoria genetic
I'm a correspondent for Voice of America
Russian service I actually have two
questions if I may do you expect that
the situation in Crimea might escalate
to the crisis that was experienced in a
posse and South Ossetia in 2008 and if
you think that this escalation is
possible what should all the parties
including the European government the
Russians the west and the Americans what
should all the parties do to try to
avoid this crisis and my second question
is what is your position or the opinion
on the allegations that the former
president of Georgia Mikhail Saakashvili
was involved in killing of the former
Prime Minister of Georgia zoo Rob Feenie
well thank you well thank you we've been
watching closely and we were and we are
very concerned about the recent
developments in Ukraine Ukraine is a
very important country for Georgia
Ukraine is a partner country to Georgia
and we have a long tradition and it's
very emotional for us and of course we
condemn any violation any violence and I
think and I very much hope that you
Ukrainian people in the Ukrainian
government will return to their European
European choice European Way as for your
question regarding Crimea you know we've
seen some alarming science of pro
occasions but we have to watch closer
and i think the the only solution to
this is the consolidated international
community and it's a support to ukraine
we have to we have to wait and see I
think the international community is
actually involved in the world is
watching closely how things will develop
in Ukraine but the reality is that
things are changing very quickly so that
we can't even follow as for a second
question I don't want to comment on this
because I can't say anything about this
the investigation is still open about
the death of former prime minister and
former chairman of parliament Rob
jaaniya and we'll see the investigation
will show us what was the reason of his
death and I don't want to speculate on
this it's a very sensitive issue thank
you um we have a little bit more time I
want them sorry for the person who just
got in line but we're not gonna have
were just have time for these two
questions you two have been standing
there very patiently so I want to make
sure you get your questions and please
ask the questions briefly and ironically
just be mindful of the time thank you
okay I'll try to be quick first off
thank you mr. prime minister for coming
and speaking with us today about the
socio-economic trajectory of Georgia and
to the Harriman Institute for hosting
this event my name is Eric Beckman I am
a graduate of the economics program here
at Columbia University and currently
working for a company called millennium
capital that is a it's headed by the
former founding CEO of Millennium
Challenge LA she needs it my question is
this given the given the lingering
effects the previous administration the
previous regimes activities regarding
businessmen and having many of them
leave the country I was very surprised
to learn that that my boss and mentor is
not even able to visit the country that
we are arranging deals for I'm curious
as to what your administration is able
to do and what you are in the process of
doing to help resolve the ambiguity ghal
status of these businessmen and women
thank you
thank you well I think this is one of
the most difficult issue and another big
challenge for our government I think we
should start each case individually the
case of mr. Russia i mentioned i will
instruct the relevant people to study
his case and I will get you an answer
but that's the that's the that's what we
inherited over 9000 businesses
properties houses were seized by the
previous government 9000 * 9 in San 90
it's 9,000 and the previous regime
prosecuted 300,000 people 300,000
Georgian citizens it's a huge number
Georgians are only 4.5 million therefore
we have to study each case it takes a
long time we've been in in the
government since october two thousand
twelve and we've already studied and
solved hundreds of cases of this type of
you know cases and I think we will while
the prosecutor's office is studying
these cases and they have a plan how to
find a solution and for your question
there will they will study in this case
and will give you an answer I understand
he's not able to trout Georgia because
he's his what I mean he's till well it's
a political exile sit right okay we will
look into this and we'll get back to you
if could to leave us your country
details thank you very much thank you
good afternoon I'm Angela wheeler and
I'm a graduate student in Colombia's
Department of urban planning I was a
fulbright student
they started to be Lisi last year and I
was unfortunate to witness a rather
violent riot that was motivated by
homophobia and anti-western sentiment
which perhaps indicated that not
everyone in Georgia is really behind
turning towards Western ideals at least
socially and especially the orthodox
church to which about eighty percent of
the georgian population subscribes you
mentioned that your administration has
adopted a human right strategy to
address minority rights in georgia will
this address LGBTQ rights well thank you
it's a good question well first of all
besides the human right strategy we're
also going to adopt the
anti-discrimination law it's all
retracted Emery's it'll be sent to the
Parliament for adoption therefore I
think this issue will be solved very
soon and I'll tell you something this
issue that you just mentioned is it
happens it may happen in every country
and we understand and i think you know
we needs to be you know it needs to you
know we need to work on this and nobody
is perfect in this world no country is
perfect and we need some more
improvements in this sector we've done
we've done a lot of we've done a great
job i would say because we liberated the
I mean the unique human strike human
right strategy and we drafted the
anti-discrimination law and this will be
you know adopted very soon the previous
government didn't do this I don't know
why they didn't do it but we're doing
this I also would want to tell you that
every year if you look at the for
example in 2011 2010 2009 all these type
of demo demonstrations of LGBT there
were I mean there were out saying for us
they were beaten by but others and the
police couldn't protect him this was the
only case single case where nobody was
injured or nobody was attacked and I
personally was involved in protecting
the these people so well we understand
it's a it is a problem it is a problem
in maybe in every country but we're
working on it
we're working to improve the human
rights situation and lastly I wanted to
tell you that Georgia has been a very
tolerant country for many centuries of
course it needs to be improved but we
have we are very experienced in
intolerance in general thank you thank
you thank you thank you to everybody for
coming participating today thank you mr.
Prime Minister has really been absolute
pleasure having you at Columbia we look
forward to having you again in the not
too distant future thank you